well since we've learned about this
variant our strategy has been to buy
time time to assess it and to build our
defenses there's still a lot of
uncertainty but we are learning more all
the time and there have been reports
some of them published yesterday uh on
the risk of hospitalization and also the
uk health security agency will be
publishing its own analysis on the risk
of hospitalization later today now these
early reports they do suggest that the
risk of hospitalization is lower than
delta and that of course is is good
that's encouraging news
and and
they're not very clear yet though on by
how much that risk is reduced and we do
know with omicron that it does spread a
lot more quickly it's a lot more
infectious than delta so any advantage
gained from a reduced risk of
hospitalization needs to be set against
that and we know for example if if a
much smaller percentage of people are at
the risk of hospitalization if that's a
smaller percentage of a much larger
number there could be still significant
hospitalization what my scientists have
been absolutely clear to me about and
just from my latest meeting with them
yesterday evening having looked at these
reports is that the
our best way to to deal with this the
best way to protect ourselves is through
vaccinations and in particular the
booster program it is now even more
important to come forward and to get
boosted and the nhs the armed forces are
volunteers they're doing a fantastic job
in increasing capacity hitting new
records every day but we need more
people to come forward and get boosted
protect themselves their community their
loved ones you know really the best
christmas present you could give anyone
this christmas is to get boosted now um
the other home nations know what
restrictions are going to be and when
they're going to be brought in when are
we going to get clarity for england
well we do have clarity i mean the
government has taken action already the
so-called plan b people are behaving
sensibly and much more cautiously since
they've learned about this variant and
and as i said we're getting more data uh
all the time we're clear that there's no
need for any kind of further
restrictions of any type uh before
christmas but of course we will keep the
situation under review the questions
after christmas people know what's
happening in wales and scotland
and when are we going to find out what's
happening there's going to be
announcement this week at any point or
are we going to get further
clarification
later in the week
we're not planning any further
announcements uh this week uh you know i
want people to uh to despite the the
caution that we're all taking the
sensible caution you know people should
enjoy their christmases with their
families and friends of course remain
cautious and we will keep the situation
under review we're learning more all the
time as we have done from this new data
and we will keep analyzing that data and
if we need to do anything more we will
but nothing more is going to happen
before christmas
does the latest data mean that there
won't be any restriction in england then
have the other nations jump the gun do
you think well as i say that the latest
data it is good news because of course
we we want to make sure we're doing
everything we can to reduce the risk of
hospitalization and it's encouraging
news but it's it's not clear enough yet
by how much that risk is reduced and we
do know that the higher infection rate
uh it should be set against uh the the
reports uh from this latest data but
again the most important thing anyone
can do is to get vaccinated is the best
way to protect ourselves this latest
data you make that abundantly clear it
couldn't be more clear protect
yourselves by getting boosted in
particular and please come forward to do
that um it safe to be hugging elderly
relatives this christmas of their
meeting other family look people i think
uh uh have been very sensible throughout
this pandemic and uh
if you are meeting people that are more
vulnerable it might be your elderly
relative you know i think a really
sensible thing to do is to take a
lateral flow test and just make sure
you're negative and just one final
question and what's the threshold for
hospitalizations or nhs staff sickness
when you feel it be necessary to take
further steps to protect the nhs well
obviously we work incredibly closely in
my department with our colleagues in the
nhs
they're aware of the heightened risk of
hospitalization and they are putting
together plans to deal with that but the
biggest thing that they're doing
actually in the nhs which is going to
help us more than anything is the
vaccination program and to get boosted
now
and uh how concerned you about nhs staff
absences in the light of the current
situation and forecasters we of the nhs
workforce it was already under pressure
before omicron came along there's
increased pressure there as we're seeing
in many workforces at the moment
especially if someone needs to isolate
if they have a a positive case uh but
some of the recent moves we've had for
moving to ten day to seven day isolation
if you take tests in the last two days i
think all of this will help